hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Suicide Squad Easter eggs video
there was about 10 minutes of The Joker
that was cut out of the film so I'm sure
there's a bunch more Easter eggs and
that that will find out about when the
DVDs released but just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the movie
yet not all these will be in
chronological order but I'll try to go
from the start of the movie to the end
of the movie so one of the biggest ones
early on is they basically describe the
plot of Superman to when they're in the
White House and the guy says what if
another Kryptonian were to come down who
doesn't share Superman's values and rip
the roof of the White House off and grab
the president they're basically talking
about Superman - where's odd and the
other evil Kryptonians from the Phantom
Zone ripped the roof of the White House
off and Lex Luthor just plants his butt
in the president's chair so that kind of
lets you know that the movie does invoke
a lot of deep cuts from all the DC
movies as well as the comics but you
know most of the stuff that they do is
from the comics so like I said sort of
the macro arc of the movie is based on
the nightshade Odyssey which is a
Suicide Squad story from the Jim
Australia years it's all about the team
discovering the enchantress really isn't
possessed by the enchantress as they
describe her in the movie it turns out
to be this succubus which is someone
that's way worse and is connected to
someone from the nightshade realm which
is another dimension so the succubus has
a brother named the Incubus that's
trapped in the nightshade realm that's
trying to get back to our world
so like the big hulking other villain of
the movie that doesn't speak a lot is
called the Incubus and Suicide Squad so
they basically combined a couple
different characters in that form sort
of the a story for Suicide Squad like
they have to go to Midway city to stop
this supernatural threat that's created
by enchantress but it turns out she's
possessed by something that's way worse
that takes over her so they did change a
lot from that comic book storyline but
that's what they're invoking the
nightshade Odyssey so enchantress what
about her it seemed like the movie was
trying to turn her into the villain so
while June moon does resurface at the
end of the movie they leave it in a
relatively ambiguous way now I feel like
that's one of the failures of the movie
is it doesn't really let you know what
the status of enchantress is after this
movie because she's a huge comic book
character so I think to their benefit
future sequels could
which on that if they want to use the
character again like they could say that
enchantress really isn't gone even
though you think that she's gone
the thing that possessed turned this
movie was something that was worse so
that's all behind the scenes
storytelling stuff but in the comics
enchantress is never a bad character
it's really her being taken over by
things that are much much worse speaking
of which much much worse Amanda Waller
probably the true villain of the film
all the terrible things that happen in
the movie or a direct result of the
decisions that she makes so a lot of the
way she goes about recruiting the
Suicide Squad and the chips that she
uses to blow them up is straight out of
the comics Belle Reve debuted in 1987 in
Suicide Squad number one it served as
kind of like a base for Task Force X
which is actually the true name of
Suicide Squad and you see a slipknot is
so careful to help demonstrate they get
their heads blown off now they did it in
the animated movie using the character
cagey beast but they actually like the
movie moment is directly ripped from a
1989 Suicide Squad comic so Suicide
Squad number 9 Captain Boomerang tries
to convince Slipknot to make a run for
it he does boom gets blown up by Rick
black they even did the Alex Ross cover
of the Paul Dini Harley Quinn Batman
story so you literally see them in a
montage make this pose as they're
flashing back to the origin of Harley
Quinn now of course they break the story
of Harley quit like how she became
Harley Quinn up through the movie in a
series of flashbacks you see her in
Arkham Asylum
you know nice deep cut for the Batman
comics she's trying to treat the Joker
but ends up falling in love with him has
Stockholm Syndrome helps him escape and
then he slowly turns her into the Harley
Quinn that you know today I'm not gonna
hurt you I'm just gonna hurt you real
real bad so you also revisit a lot of
Joker origin moments where he's like
would you die for me well would you live
for me and then she just kind of throws
herself off of the ace chemicals
platform into the VAT of chemicals but
as much as that's deep cuts for Harley
Quinn's origin story also deep cuts
revisiting Joker origin moments from The
Killing Joke now The Killing Joke is an
important comic book for a number of
different reasons you know especially
Batgirl Barbara Gordon you know Batman
specific things they
reference a lot of Killing Joke Batman
stuff in this they don't reference death
in the family even though Batman is in
the movie who I'll talk about in a
second but they did say that they cut a
lot of the Joker scenes out of Suicide
Squad so the next time you see Harley
Quinn and the Joker show up in a movie
they might dedicate more of the movie to
telling their origin story especially
the Joker's origin story but like I said
really this is about Harley Quinn's
origin story so you don't see a lot of
Red Hood Joker origin story stuff
happening you could see the baseball bat
is inspired by Arkham Knight but the
mallet that she picks up in that seat
you know where she's pulling her costume
out of those boxes was more of her
primary weapon in the comics I know
everybody was hoping that Scott Eastwood
was playing Nightwing he just played a
character called GQ so people are like
maybe they're talking about green arrow
or something like that no I think that
he's just there because David Ayer
really loves Clint Eastwood and he
wanted more you know like human soldiers
that were not part of the Suicide Squad
to balance the team out because he
almost doesn't do anything in the film
like he nods a lot he shoots his gun and
he like fist bumps a little bit that's
really all he does in the film but there
is a lesser character when the Joker's
trying to rescue Harley Quinn later in
the film
that's called Johnny Frost he's the one
that's operating that big machine gun
when they think they're being rescued
and they're like wait a minute in the
Joker's wearing his Alex Ross tuxedo and
they opened fire the person firing the
machine gun is named Johnny Frost Johnny
Frost is a character who works for the
Joker in a book just called Joker the
way they introduce all the characters
like the way they explained their
backstories in the movie is very true to
the comics like katana they talk about
her husband dying her stealing the sword
from the man who killed her husband the
sword itself stealing the souls of the
people that he kills better not let her
kill you with that because it traps the
souls of its victims
moving into Batman stuff there's a whole
lot of Batman in this film I love the
way the film used him but Deadshot gets
taken in by him that's how he ends up in
Belle Reve Deadshot's first appearance
in the comics was in Batman number 59
way back in the 1950s now the look of
the character was very different the
Deadshot costume that most of you
recognized from the comics like the the
special hood that he wears didn't debut
till 1977 in Detective Comics number 474
so like Deadshot showed up in this
costume way back in the 1950
then didn't come back till the 1970s so
if you wonder in this flashback when
Will Smith is walking with his daughter
when they're telling the story of how he
got arrested why he's dressed like a
pimp it's because David Ayer is doing an
homage to the dead shot of the 1970s
when he came back with his new costume
you'll of course remember the
mid-credits scene where Batman is
getting files to assemble the Justice
League from Amanda Waller she actually
references nighttime activities meaning
this is actually really important that
Amanda Waller knows that Bruce Wayne is
Batman and then Bruce Wayne kind of
throws it back in her face as he's
walking out shut it down or me and my
friends will do it for you he's telling
Amanda Waller to shut down Task Force X
or he'll bring in the Justice League to
shut them down but he's saying I like to
make friends so imagine this moment
happening in the timeline before what
happens during the Justice League
trailer from comic-con which I've
already done a video for so I'll put a
link in the description for that so like
after you watch the Suicide Squad Easter
eggs you can watch the Justice League
video but more Justice League stuff so
the flash is in the movie he captures
Captain Boomerang the reason they did it
that way is you know just have a little
bit of fun to invoke the larger DC movie
universe but Captain Boomerang
originally first appeared in the flash
comics so they're being very true to
Captain boomerangs origin story the TV
shows did the exact same thing they used
him for the crossover episode because
arrow kind of did Suicide Squad and
before that he'd been a flash rogue so
he's like the perfect character to use
on both of those shows but El Diablo one
of the best characters in the movie El
Diablo is one of the few characters that
actually has a really satisfying arc
later in the film he says I'm going to
show you what I truly am any kind of
changes form into this big demon figure
so El Diablo in the comics is actually
possessed by a demon that's where he
gets his power from but in the movie he
says that he was born that way so you
could say he was born part demon but
he's also a supernatural magical
character from the DC Universe the same
way Enchantress's so the movie kind of
invoked magic in a way that the movies
haven't done before the last big Easter
egg that I noticed was the John
Ostrander one so they named the building
that they rescue Amanda Waller from in
Midway City after John Ostrander it's at
the John Ostrander Federal Building
John Austria of course is the person who
made Suicide Squad
famous now the Suicide Squad was already
an idea in the comic when John Ostrander
came along he's just the one that turned
it into the modern Suicide Squad that
everybody thinks about when they think
about Suicide Squad so if you guys
spotted any other easter eggs in the
movie that i didn't mention in the video
just write them below in the comments
but I almost forgot for those of you
that are wondering Zack Snyder did
direct a scene during Suicide Squad it
was the flash scene where he captures
Captain Boomerang so bit of a DC movies
Easter Egg if you remember earlier this
year there was a bunch of reorganization
behind the scenes Geoff Johns became one
of the new gods of DC he's now kind of
like the Kevin Feige of DC movies so he
really wasn't that involved with the
making of Suicide Squad or Batman vs
Superman
the first Geoff Johns DC movie is
actually Wonder Woman so if you're big
Geoff Johns fan and you're really
excited about what he's gonna do with
the DC movies now that he's in charge
you will see a lot of that on a Wonder
Woman like Geoff Johns had nothing to do
with the story of Batman V Superman or
Suicide Squad he was actually one of the
co riders of the Wonder Woman movie so I
think it's going to be fantastic
so in related news if you guys didn't
know there's a new round of the giveaway
it's just a $20 Amazon gift card all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video my
next video is going to be some Deadpool
2 they just been talking about the
Deadpool sequel then I'll do a new video
later this weekend about the Suicide
Squad sequels that I think they're going
to make ETA's already making a ton of
money there will definitely be more
Suicide Squad where you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for the Justice League trailer and you
can click here for my review video thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you